here's a guardian article
from when is it uh two days ago
ioc that's the international olympic
committee praises weightlifter laurel
hubbard before transgender athletes
olympic debut
if i may have my screen back so this um
this person laurel hubbard i think
is going to debut on monday so has not
happened yet
i'm just going to quote a few more
places from the article but from my
screen so don't don't show
zach the ioc's medical and science
director dr richard
richard budget said quote everyone
agrees that trans women are women
hubbard's participation in tokyo hubbard
being the athlete
has proved controversial with her
supporters hailing at his historic
moment for trans rights
with the ioc's critics believing that
the 42 year old new zealander
who had never competed internationally
until transitioning at 35
has an unfair and substantial advantage
final quote recent scientific papers
have also shown that anyone who
undergoes male puberty retains
significant advantages in power and
strength even after taking medication to
suppress their testosterone levels
and one of the papers you know you don't
say right one of the papers that they
cite here
or maybe the only paper is this
excellent paper by emma hilton and tommy
lundberg
that just came out and that we managed
to just sneak into our book just before
final final edits were done called
transgender women in the female category
of sport
perspectives on testosterone suppression
and performance advantage
so one thing i want to say here is you
know slight kudos to the guardian
for actually you know this is it's it's
not it's by no means a perfect piece but
the guardian has been
a sort of canary in the coal mine of of
woke ridiculousness for a while now
and um zach can i thank you um
has been a canary in the coal mine for
woke of woke ridiculousness for a while
now but
this piece actually has um not just some
nuance but actually some truth
and you know having just just simply
putting it out there
that the ioc's medical and science
director
says everyone agrees that trans women
are women well
no no they don't and if you've
if you've got a degree and you're the
director of both medicine and science
the fact that you can say that means
you're not fit for your job yeah
like you're just not and you know
who cares a 35 year old person
transitions never having competed before
and now seven years later is in the
olympics
in it's not even
like fencing right which like like
everything is sex segregated everything
is sex segregated but
weightlifting for christ's sakes yeah
like even our
pelvises being differently shaped makes
men more stable
on their feet this is insanity
yeah like i can't believe we're here
i can't believe we're here right and you
know that it's heralded as
a major victory for trans rights when
it's actually a major setback for women
right yes so so so disappear
women's sports right and in fact um i
just want to read a small bit from
this book helen joyce is trans when
ideology meets reality this just came
out this month
we got a preview copy and i have not
read the whole thing i
have skimmed it all and read some of it
and it is as i was expecting
um quite excellent and she does a
section on
um on basically a history
of of females of female sports as well
which i didn't i didn't know and is
quite interesting and basically
you know like with like with the
recognition that women
have different ideologies and
manifestations of disease and we need to
recognize that in our health care
practices in order not to be killing
women because we think they're just men
but smaller
so too um have just recently
women been not just allowed to compete
at the elite levels
um but been given their you know our own
places to do so because when women
compete directly with men
unless it's in something that is
explicitly co-ed like mixed doubles in
tennis or you know the sport that we
played a lot of ultimate frisbee really
allows
for wonderful games when they're co-ed
and you know i played i played a lot of
co-ed frisbee i played competitively on
the
women's team at university of michigan
and watched therefore in a lot of
tournaments
a lot of men's play a lot of women's
play a lot of co-ed play
and frankly in that particular game and
there are a lot of games that
a lot of sports that don't allow for it
but in that particular game
co-ed he's going to knock that over just
move that um
coed play allows for the best of both
right like well well hold on a second
for those who haven't played it
it specifically neutralizes the problem
right if you take the big dude on the
ultimate team and he teams up against
the
the little they're doing a man on he
lines up against a woman right and
that's who he's he'll shut her down
and that's considered unfair so the idea
is when you line up before
a particular point you line up against
somebody with whom you are appropriately
matched so it can be a man against a
woman if they're appropriately matched
but the point is it neutralizes
the ability of men to shut down women
right but i mean also if you're playing
zone rather than man on defense that
that further neutralizes it but you do
need i mean it's understood that you
need to have uh an equivalent or
you know usually an equivalent sex ratio
on both teams if you've got you know and
this is true
in um co-ed competition where um
i think you're it's been a while since i
played i've ruptured my achilles tendon
doing so um
i think you're always required to have
two women um on at a time
and um basically if you claim you're a
co-ed team and you only have men on the
on the
on the field at the time you're not
effectively playing co-ed
but what i was going to say is um an all
an all-male game which are fun to watch
um
you know there's just this raw
physicality um but they tend to be
long hucks and fast runs into the end
zone you know layouts spectacular
all of this but the points are short
most people don't touch the disc a lot
of people don't get play
and many beers are held
no but you know in women's games
it tends to be almost the opposite like
a lot of short passes
a lot of focus on making sure you know
not in the competitive stuff there's not
as much focus on like make sure everyone
touches the disc but
um you know shorter passes fewer long
hawks
longer points um gets a little tedious
and you know i i never liked playing the
women's
the women's game as much as i liked
playing the co-ed games because it has
both because there is more strategy and
focus on how are you going to do this if
you got some
you got some six foot six guy who's
going to show up and
shut you down anytime you get the disc
you gotta you've got to think
strategically
and realize that your strength isn't
necessarily in
raw power and size and speed right
so anyway in in that case and it won't
be the case in a lot of team sports but
in that case there is actually a way to
play co-ed that is wonderful and i would
say you know that's what that's what
life offers as well
let me just read one paragraph from the
introduction of helen joyce's
new book um
she begins by saying oh no just just one
paragraph here
this is a book about trans activism it
is a story about
policy and institutional capture of
charitable foundations controlled by
billionaires joining forces
with activist groups to pump money into
lobbying behind the scenes for legal
change
they have won over big political parties
notably america's democrats and big
businesses including tech giants
they are backed too by academics and
gender studies queer theory and allied
fields
and by the pharmaceutical and healthcare
industries which have woken up to the
fortunes to be made
from gender affirming medicine so
it's the same everywhere right we got
the same kind of story
everywhere we got capture and activism
that may or may not be coordinated but
um its effect is as if it was
yeah and i uh you know i hate that this
is now
manifesting in new realms but really the
point is
this was what uh we were trying to warn
people about when we were talking
about um the danger that capture and
corruption
poses to our ability to function
coherently and you know the fact that
you're seeing it across
uh the social media platforms the fact
that you're seeing it in science
medicine
health policy um you know our military
everything the fact that everything is
susceptible to being pushed into insane
uh
contortions is just evidence that we
have a very serious problem
right and you know evergreen many people
took to be
uh almost funny in how over the top it
was
but it was a warning right this is what
corruption does to a system it renders
it incoherent
and an incoherent system doesn't
collapse immediately but at the point
you recognize
that these you know falsehoods have
taken over
the steering mechanism it's an emergency
whether or not there's an iceberg
visible right there's going to be one at
some point